it was much more exciting than I thought
you see the flames our first video of
fluorine was a bit disappointing
there wasn't any just a few bits of
glassware and some family stories so in
the moment I'm in the office of
Professor Eric hope there is who is one
of the country's specialist in fluorine
chemistry and he knows how to handle
this terrific element safely I have no
idea what to do I'm quite excited to see
what happens one of the things you said
in that original video was on YouTube
was that you'd never what throughing was
one of the few elements that you haven't
seen so I thought they're actually
relatively few chemists who have seen
fluorine and so what I want to do is try
and show you what's actually produced
and show you elemental fluorine the
fluorine is slowly released and you can
see the pressure slowly going up the
reason that people know about fluorine
is because it is one of the really
reactive elements it will react with all
the elements in the periodic table
except neon and helium it will react
with gold it will react with silver
it'll react with platinum platinum
hexafluoride is bright red as a gas okay
so chlorine is going into the apparatus
it's going into this tube Martin you
can't see anything can you can't see
anything at all and that's because
there's only a little under two
atmospheres of fluid in there it's a
very pale yellow color as a gas a bit
disappointed but I suppose it's like
oxygen or nitrogen you can't really see
it but perhaps if we condense it as a
liquid then I'll see it properly okay so
I'm now going to call this down with the
connection to my 196 I'm going to do it
slowly it will take a little while
okay Martin do you want to help me with
this so what I want what I wanted to do
is for you to take that your away and
then I'll slide this one in so just
slide it away and back up again and
there we have nearly two inches maybe of
liquid fluorine you can go right up
that's there's no problem with that
you want to just clear a bit of
condensation off there
yeah I'm really surprised I thought it
would be pale green and it's really
quite dark yellow
if I'd been shown it I would have said
it was liquid chlorine I never seen
liquid chlorine either quite pleased
with that so basically I've got another
flowing cylinder filled up from the roof
with about five atmospheres of fluorine
in it so this is now going to release
the flurry and what I've got in this
demonstration here is just some a
scouring pad basically it's a metal
scouring pad I'm fine
it burnt a hole right through the iron
wall it's extraordinary the iron looks
as if it's rusted that the rusty color
is actually iron fluoride when maybe a
bit of iron oxide from the hot iron
reacting with the oxygen in the air were
the reason that fluorine makes up strong
bonds is because it is a small atom and
the nucleus is relatively highly charged
because it's right on the right-hand
side of the periodic table but the
electrons don't shield this nucleus so
it is very so-called electronegative it
attracts electrons to itself from other
elements I've changed the prop now for
some just normal BBQ briquettes so this
is pure carbon so we haven't done
anything this is coal charcoal and coal
gas and the gas just touching it is
enough to start the fire think of that
just the cold gas setting things on fire
most chemists are really too frightened
to work with fluorine you can't use it
in glass vessels it doesn't attack glass
but if the glass is a tiny bit wet and
most glass has moisture absorbed to it
then the fluorine forms hydrogen
fluoride when it reacts with the water
and the hydrogen fluoride just eats
through the glass so you need to use
equipment made out of metal usually
nickel and the fluorine reacts with the
surface of the nickel the first time you
use it and then you get a layer on the
surface that protects the rest of the
metal so this is again flooring with
sulfur so you can oxidize the sulfur
probably to solve a tetrafluoride or
sulfur hexafluoride
Florine has this reputation for being
very reactive and very dangerous and
something to be careful about but aren't
there fluid items in my toothpaste there
are your toothpaste contains fluoride
and just in the same way that you can
eat sodium chloride table salt which
contains chlorine you can use fluorides
and once the fluorine has got an extra
electron for example from the tin in tin
fluoride which is often used in
toothpaste or sodium fluoride it's got
what it wants and it's not very reactive
and the way it works with teeth
is that the enamel of your teeth is a
compound of calcium called apatite which
normally the apatite in your teeth can
dissolve quite easily an acid for
example if you eat sweets or drink some
fizzy drinks they have enough acid to
start dissolving the surface of your
teeth but if you brush your teeth with
fluoride some of the apatite which
contains OAH groups some of these are
replaced with fluoride and you make a
material called fluoro apatite which is
much less soluble in acid so it can't be
attacked too easily so you don't get
holes in your teeth